all right uber is rolling out new
features to improve safety and privacy
passengers phone numbers will stay
hidden and addresses will disappear when
trips are over lubbers new ride check
feature can detect when a vehicle is in
a crash or makes an unplanned stop the
app will ask the driver and passenger
confirm they are okay and will help call
9-1-1 uber is also planning to get its
driverless cars back on the road Kris
Van Cleave spoke to uber CEO Derrick
Arthur scollay one asked about
self-driving sure cars Hoover had of had
that accident in Arizona that was a
horrible tragedy you've since hold back
from self-driving development what have
you learned from that accident well I
think the accident led us to pull back
and to relook at our processes
operational processes technology
processes from front to back so that
when we get back on the road and we are
going to get back on the road in
self-driving and start testing our
technology again we do so in this safest
manner possible do you have a timeline
for when you'd like to see self-driving
testing resumed this year this year but
when 2018 we have a lot of work ahead of
us and it's going to be with dialogue in
which the cities with the cities that we
operate in
Qasr Shah he says uber is still on track
to go public next year